The nominees for performance
by an actress in a leading role
are Jane Fonda in
The Morning After.
Sissy Spacek
in Crimes of the Heart.
Kathleen Turner in
Peggy Sue Got Married.
Marlee Matlin
in Children of a Lesser God.
Sigourney Weaver in Alien.
And the winner is,
Marlee Matlin.
I am.
I just want to
thank a lot of people.
To tell you the truth,
I didn't
prepare for this speech,
but I definitely want to thank
the Academy and its members.
And I want to thank
all those special people
in the film
and I can name them
Randa Haines, Patrick Palmer,
the entire cast and crew,
and particularly William Hurt
for his great support
and love in this film.
And I want to thank
my mother and father,
Eric, Marc, Gloria,
Zachary and Liz.
They're here tonight with me.
And I just want to thank
all of you.
I love you.